[Musique]
arnaud la france sap avait la france
c'est sérieux la politique ne prend pas
pour toi mais c'est juste comme tu sais
rien faire
bush par quatre longues comme oui mais
catherine et crée sa compagnie france et
aux français avait des couilles mais
sera le français aussi
tiens et moi j'vais pas de pamiers sur
une photo pascal donc il faut les couper
non on va plutôt baisser les stores vous
êtes le nouveau stagiaire
non je suis sans nouvelle assistante
avis je m'enfonce fils de colin j'aime
pas trop quoi qu'on m'appelle bogolans
dans la bouche c'est affectueux c'est
toi qui a écrit ça je vais fermer ma
porte
c'est vrai j'en ai vu d'autres des
iguanes et 1 c'est ça qu'il nous faut
pour demain tu mérite une récompense qui
m'attendent la charge revient la
politique familiale pont près de
phéromones
on avait dit papier colonne on est tout
blanc ibis justement on a réussi à
éliminer le côté grille d'égout du
papier biodégradable classique pour les
gens biodégradable c'est forcément
griller des gueux là on verra l'impact
ne se fait pas le teindre en vrille
quand même pourquoi pas j'en sais rien
moi ça l'image accroissent à la france
elle attend que ça j'allais d'apprendre
comme ça du médecin tarifs comme un
homme doux jeu verra pourquoi le tu
réduis dina à votre pire
catherine on avait parlé d'une petite
vie ondulations dans la ville pour aller
à la rencontre des gens les gens les
électeurs ah oui